that's it that's the strongest passion
i wanted to make sure that what happened
to me and that's in that memorial
won't happen again not to me not to
others and that's a need for everyone
maybe not at the moment but someday
all over the world for all of us we are
gonna have this name
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel stanford leap and
birthright excel welcome
to 20 minute leaders today we're going
to be talking to an entrepreneur that is
dealing with what's happening
after life to those that are still
in life meet shahrukh the ceo of
eternity
is an israeli entrepreneur based in tel
aviv israel he is the ceo of eternity a
post-investment israeli startup
established to change the way people
commemorate and celebrate the life
stories
of their loved ones in a respectful
accessible and moving way shah majored
in business and data science at idc
and graduated with honors his managerial
approaches all around
hands-on involvement the idea to
execution process
and data-driven decision making shahar
palette thank you so much for joining me
in 20 minute leaders how are you for
having me i'm great how are you
i'm good we know each other for quite
some time since birthright excel
in that in that amazing summer and today
you're the ceo of eternity
in an incredible market in a domain that
pretty much nobody talks about but
everybody should be because it's so
fascinating so hopefully
a few competitors will will come out due
to this episode
but but really you know i mean they're
coming the way that you're doing it i
think it's just
is it's so interesting just you know
intellectually
curious speaking uh tell me a little bit
about your
your own journey and how did you end up
getting involved with eternity and what
are you doing today
okay so my background
i came from a very different field i was
in public diplomacy yeah
my passion was representing israel on
different
stadiums around the world i've been to
new york city i've been to china i've
been to europe
to represent israel i've lived in new
york city for two and a half years
bridging the gap between the communities
on the upper east side in manhattan and
israel
doing some good work i think and uh
coming back was was a shocker seeing
that the world that i used to live in
in new york has changed the world
i came to live in israel after two and a
half years then i kept representing
israel i wanted some delegations to
china
and knew that this is the field that i
want to continue
standing um but then something changed
when i lived in new york three of my
grandparents passed away
seeing their funerals via facetime was
something that
it wasn't good it wasn't it wasn't easy
i was
very very connected to to all of them
basically
uh when i got back to israel i wanted to
do something for them two of them were
volatile survivors
and that's a fail it was always dear to
my heart
so i organized some events to not just
bring the subject up and educate the
younger generations about the holocaust
but also to take it abroad
to show to other people and have them
understand and remember the holocaust
and make sure it never happens again
i went to my grandparents memorial in
the funeral
uh in the in the uh cemetery
and i remember talking about them
because i'm the one that gives the
speeches in the family i don't write
anything i just go there and give some
speeches
um my nephews and nieces were next to me
they were bored i didn't know them and i
kept talking and telling stories and i
suddenly understood that i forgot some
of the stories
and my memory changes and it's just it's
so subjective
and then i saw my nieces and nephews
again and they were bored
and they looked at this piece of stone
the tombstone and there were nothing
for them and for me they're everything
they're the reason this country exists
right now
and then i just figured there is no way
the memory of my
grandparents the heroes the founders of
israel is going to end in my generation
and i wanted to change it because my
nieces and nephews and my future kids
they're not gonna open the books they
read right they wrote they're not gonna
open the
the albums or see some photos from from
the old days
they are gonna be digital they are gonna
take it to 21st century
and then i knew we had to do something
so the idea of eternity came from a
personal need
for me and for the other co-founders
that's it that's the strongest
passion i wanted to make sure that what
happened to me
and that's in that memorial what
happened again not to me not to others
and that's a need for everyone maybe not
at the moment but someday
all over the world for all of us we are
going to have this need and
fix it and so the trend that you're
talking about here obviously this
personal experience is something that is
you know uniform to billions of people
around the world
this need that you're describing of
needing to remember
needing to be able to share these
memories especially with younger
generation that is all about
visuals and all about entertainment and
they need to interact with
with the memories that we're taking
pictures of and that's something that
we're lacking
why are we lacking this why don't we
have a good solution for remembering the
loved ones that we lost
i think there are two reasons one of
them this is just a very old
i guess market because people didn't
want to change it
for them memory is just is sacred and
you have to do it the old traditional
way
and that's false because the world
changes
technology is taking a larger and larger
part in
all of our lives and we can't just leave
this
important aspect of our lives behind
with technology and the other part
is all of these high-tech companies and
giant companies didn't want to touch
these fields
you didn't want to touch this market
because it's it's taboo for some of them
so i believe this is the reason or these
are the reasons that
this market is is almost empty it's like
a blue ocean because not many people
enough organizations or companies
wanted to to address it and that's a
need that we need to address
not because it's tragic most dead or
let's say more than 80 are known and
some of them
you just have to live with some of them
still very tragic but
commemorating our loved ones telling
their stories
making sure their legacy lives on is
something that
that we all need to cherish it's
something we all need to do and that's
the reason eternity came to life
so as you're thinking now is the the
head of a ceo and obviously you know
i completely understand the need and
obviously i think any person
that listens to the story immediately
understands the need especially if
they've lost
a loved one and even if they're not just
understanding you know that that pain
how are you how are you even thinking
about addressing it so you're you know
there's a million ways to go about this
with technological solutions with social
solutions
you have to focus as a company how are
you tackling this problem
so before we started even touching the
subject we had a very very large market
research but it's not us sitting
googling and looking for numbers it's us
going and talking to people
seeing if this if this need is really as
vast as we thought
and we saw that it's even larger that
the need to tell the stories
do need to even choose your own legacy
not just commemorate your loved ones
choose your own legacy
choose your loved ones legacy even
before the sad moment happens
we knew that something needs to change
and we had to do three things
it's not a market you can just bring
technology and make it happen
it's not it's something that needs to be
different because the personal
real touch between the person and the
customer
or the customer successful anyone with
the customers
that the human touch is something you
just can't put aside
you can't you have to make it emotional
this is such an emotional moment it's
such an emotional
process even if it's not a recent death
even if it happened
10 years ago you have to give it a
personal touch you have to bring the
human touch
and that's the way to do it and second
is really bring technology it's not just
deep tech that helps that the techie
people
create memorial sites or anything else
it's something that has to work with
everyone
with the 90 of humanity that has
internet connection and can just log on
and create something beautiful for their
loved ones
and it's not something that is easy to
do because it's so deep
and when you think of that when you look
at a product when you look at what we do
you see that when people who are not as
tacky as you and me let's say this way
they don't believe they can do something
like that for the loved ones and make it
eternal
make it live for eternity and that's
that's the biggest goal
to make sure it's accessible to make
sure it's affordable to all
we're not a company it will only help
those who have the money
have the resources we want to help all
we want to make sure that even those who
can't afford it
will be able to commemorate the loved
ones because it doesn't matter if
they're
presidents or the simplest people who
i don't know you know what i'm talking
about everyone should be commemorated
everyone had purpose in this world and
that's our goal
and it's accessible make sure it's
affordable
make sure it's respectful right and so
where's the low-hanging fruit at this
point
in terms of helping you know the
millions of people around the world
better commemorate their loved ones well
we're you know what where are we
starting out from
so as business-wise talking we started
in israel
as a pilot we believe the market here is
a great
it's great i guess market research for
us to really understand
if we're right and we have tried and
we've started and the results are
amazing
so we took it a bit farther to the
states and we saw that the need is
really
is mutual so the way to do it is to take
the products we've created and make sure
that their
market fit make sure that it really
works with the customers we have
and it's really hard to define the
customers because it's everyone
it's everyone from younger i guess
young adults to elderly
um to be able to speak different
languages who some of them that
never use the internet everyone needs to
get
the help and the way to commemorate
their loved ones and that's
how we do it we basically make sure it's
affordable and accessible to all
not just by our tech but also by our
team
because we have people going around
israel as we speak right now actually i
have a few people
working with some customers and helping
them just go and do it for them
because as i told you you can't really
um detach
the human parts and so what are they
actually doing what is the actual thing
they're going
two people two families houses and
creating more websites
for their loved ones helping them do it
for them collect the materials
write the text upload the photos upload
the videos the recordings
um guide them into creating the most
beautiful and respectful websites
for them and then they want to help them
bring
this memory this tribute to life in the
physical world
so to help to connect them to those who
want to
physically commemorate them they can be
in benches or parks or
any other parts of universities and
schools and municipalities and
hospitals because all of them basically
want to create
um commemorations and we can bridge the
gap between the two parts the
organizations that want to fundraise
or commemorate or build new um
establishments so build anything on
behalf of someone
and those who wish to commemorate and up
until now
no one could have done this uh this
connection because there are two issues
here
the financial one that most physical
commemorations are super expensive
because they took out all the less
expensive ones that are also beautiful
commemorations
and we knew how to do it and the second
one is bureaucracy
that if you wanted to commemorate your
loved ones or let's say a normal person
wanted to do that
they had a really really hard time doing
it because of bureaucracy
i served in a unit in the idf and we
wanted to commemorate
the unit commander that passed away that
died in one of the operations
and we had the plans going and
everything was approved by the
municipality we fundraised we raised
more than we needed
it was two and a half years ago and
still nothing happened
because people woke up and then
bureaucracy happened and we wanted to
bridge this cup
and with us this is just not going to
happen so the bureaucracy i mean
getting the clearance from the
municipality or whatever
place you want to commemorate to to
allow for that to happen and to
because what it sounds to me that the
gap that you're also describing here
is the lack of experience that they may
have with groups that are looking to
commemorate especially on a smaller
scale so if you want to
you know donate a building for millions
of dollars you know then they have a
dedicated person working with you to
make it happen
and that's still a lot of bureaucracy
but there's a lot of incentive
from the other side and what you're
saying here is we're actually going to
find a way to streamline this process
to make it easy both in both sides of
the marketplace both for the consumers
who are looking to commemorate but also
for the municipality or the campuses
that are looking to help them do that
now what is the incentive
for the for the business to business
side so
in this specific product let's say the
physical commemoration one yeah
those organizations and that's a large
number of organizations as i said when a
spot is uh
non-profits nature organizations schools
hospitals etc
basically they spend hundreds of
thousands to millions of dollars a year
fundraising they have dedicated people
that all they do is
look for donors and they throw gala
gala events and uh they make sure they
have the most beautiful presentations to
get the donors
what we tell them is take the materials
you have
upload it to our website and that's it
we're gonna find the people who wish to
commemorate yeah they might be donors
but we don't call them donors
there are families who want to
commemorate the loved ones all they have
to do
is choose the collaborative topic
education
um health nature
religion whatever choose their budget
choose their location and just like in a
menu they get all the commemoration
options in front of their faces all they
have to do is click
choose the one they want they can share
it with their families
pay the amount of money that the
organization
decided to put it there if they can't
afford it they can start a fundraising a
crowdfunding campaign in a website on a
platform they basically get the money
with friends with family until they can
commemorate their loved ones and then
let's chase
let's say they they found a bench or a
park in a city and it cost ten thousand
dollars
in a few weeks or the amount of time the
organization said maybe less maybe more
they're going to be a park inside the
municipality
where the location was put in the site
with the commercial commercial site
commemorative sign i'm sorry
on behalf of this and that the left one
and a qr code connected
to their more website they created an
eternity
so now this this memory not just gonna
leave on
digitally it's gonna leave one
physically as well and it's not just for
people who had the wealth to do it
it's not just for people who were famous
enough to be commemorated
it's for everyone and that's our goal
right and so you're talking about you
know
really a full circle that this idea that
you want to memorialize somebody in the
digital world that is allowing
really anybody you know from now to
eternity to
reflect back on this person and not just
look objectively you mentioned before we
started recording not just a wikipedia
page but really a timeline of their big
events in their life
and and who they were as a person what
their purpose in this world was and
their contribution to this world and
society
but then you're saying but and the
physical aspect you're reflecting back
on
on your nephews right and how you're
saying they're sitting there
and and they're not interested because
they're not living the person that we're
commemorating
but through a qr code or beacons or
whatever it may be
you're bringing them you're connecting
them to the digital world through the
physical world and making that bridge
right
yeah now we've been to new york together
i went to central park very often yeah
and on some of the benches you see names
yeah
but you've just seen names yeah who was
that person yep
who was he who was she who are they yep
now it's not just just going to be the
names you're going to have the beacon
the qr code all you have to do is scan
it
and you enter the person's life you see
who they were
but as you said it's not just going to
be the name a bio and
a picture it's going gonna be a whole
world of memory
a memorial community because we believe
a life story cannot just be told by one
one person
a life story cannot just be told by a
few photos and texts
a life story should bring all the
community that the person lived in
together
so we allow people in a few minutes
super simple
super user-friendly and super
respectful to bring the life story
to life in a very simple way all they
have to do is choose the life periods or
highlights
let's say childhood um academy
trips travels love whatever skydiving
and then just upload content it can be
in words
it can be in photo in video recording
link whatever assign it to the
timeline and just gonna connect into the
site
and then you send it to people to people
who knew that person all they have to do
is click on upload a memory or whatever
they want
and just say what the person was to them
what they meant to them
and become a part of this commemorating
community
and they're going to be part of the site
obviously with the admins approval
just like it needs to be but then it's
not just gonna
be created once and be left forever
every time an important rotation happens
or you remember the person you can log
in you can add another memory
the site will remind you that this
specific day is beautiful let's leave a
note let's leave
a candle let's light a candle for them
and let's make sure that their memory
lives on
and we believe this community the
community is the life story
beside it i mean without it i don't
think can be a full life story
right and in each life period we had a
different community we have to let them
tell the story
it can't just be us telling the story
with a few photos
and a few words it has to be together it
has to be communal and that's what we
believe in
i i think it's amazing and and i'll take
it one step further
you know maybe in a great in a greater
vision this idea that
you know if this is going to become a
place of
of memory and commemorating you know
it's also a place for people that are
going to leave the world to
to to leave their few cents and and if
this is a place where people are going
to go back and reflect
about this person's life and their
mission and their vision and their
values
well that maybe maybe there's a point
where that person also has a part in
playing
in in in in having those values written
down spoken
verbally or recorded video but but
that's for another episode and tara i
really want to thank you for coming here
and sharing this this vision i think
it's phenomenal i think
you know obviously it's an important
it's you know the values that are
driving this company and and your
passion for it are amazing i think it's
also an amazing business opportunity
which is something that we can't neglect
and
i'm a huge believer that positive impact
and drives also positive business and
and the intersection of the two is
amazing so i think what you're doing is
is totally amazing
i have a few more questions about you
not about eternity but about you
take me back to your childhood what
fascinated you as a kid
i grew up in a very very special home um
i'm the youngest of four
my dad is is a businessman that was
barely home
but it was very pushing let's say when i
brought an a minus from school he gave
me the looks
why not a plus and when i scored 25 in
basketball it was like one of 30.
and when i made it to an elite unit in
the idea why not a better unit
you see where i'm going as a child i
knew that i have to be
great no matter what i do and that was
something that
i'll forever be grateful for because he
taught me that
no matter what i do just do it well
if you want to give back to the world
just do it well
if you want to do well for yourself just
do it well and if you want to
clean your home and stay and raise the
kids which is beautiful do it well
and that's i work i mean it's thanks to
him
and my mom was the opposite she just
wanted us to be happy always and she
said no matter what you do
no matter if you're the best at it or
not just be happy so as a kid
i wanted to bring the two together i
wanted to do
to be good at what i do and i wanted to
make sure i'm happy
and that's what i do right now i work in
a business in a company that i run
and i don't feel like i go to work love
what you do i never work a day in your
life
that's how i feel every day i think
that's uh you're pretty much also
answering the second question but i'll
ask it anyway
what inspires you today at eternity we
say that
we we want to leave a mark a positive
mark in the world
and i'm gonna put eternity aside for a
second that's what i want to do
i make sure i want to make sure that
when i leave this world hopefully
many many years i want to go
when i know that i left a good mark in
the world i know that i did something
great
something that people will will say
thanks
because of it and i believe it's
possible either through business
but through giving back through other
ways
non-profits education i believe i need
to do it and that's what it pushed me
to keep going and working 24 7 to make
sure i leave a good mark in the world
amazing and three words you need to
describe yourself
i'm passionate no matter what i do i'm
passionate
about it um i could be shy
that sometimes it doesn't look like it
but i could be very shy
and i think loving
i'm a loving person to other people
sometimes to myself
and also to what i do even benny here
get some love from us
uh so i think these are the words that
came to my mind right now
thank you very very much this is amazing
thank you best of luck
thank you very much